yeah you know I have a leaky I have
leaky things in my body
I could see that yeah you know when I
was on the show I would I did Portland
Friday night and the second show on what
club at the helium how was it it's okay
fun and I was on stage and then I I was
doing a bit and all of a sudden I just
[ __ ] my pants oh yeah
have you seen your parents on stage no
I'm [ __ ] my pants like in a couple
of different places but I've never seen
pants on the stage but you and I stopped
the show yeah oh well good night and I
went back backstage and then here's the
crazy part it was the first show Friday
night cuz and then I took my pants down
it was a load of [ __ ] in my pants oh no
you don't have a leaky [ __ ]
oh my yeah and then what happened was um
here's what happened after that already
like this guy can I just finish my story
guy all right um so I could I go to the
manager I go
the manager like they manage your
[ __ ] [ __ ] dunno I go grow Oh
can you go get go to the store and get
me a mo diem ad right mo diem ad from
what the periodic table no imodium no
that's not an element bro yeah
where does honey come from huh yeah yes
I'm honey of a freeze come from the
woods yeah but he wouldn't do it yeah Oh
give me a mo DM he's a [ __ ] adult
dude no no how am I gonna do the second
show if I have diarrhea
I don't care wrap your body in something
dude get out [ __ ] boy you know paddle
the [ __ ] riddles [ __ ] boy where you
get me all that stuff oh yeah it was a
disaster Friday night you never sit your
plasma let me think about what happened
to me one time
oh I remember one time I got stuck in a
tunnel my car broke down in a tunnel in
Pittsburgh and I had to defecate
extremely and that's French actually for
[ __ ] yeah yeah and I did defecate and uh
so I got my back seat of my car and the
only like I didn't have any choice this
was like you know it was like something
gotten into my body like a pink I had
got into my stomach
well you know and all the [ __ ] in my
body was coming out of my
body yet it was I in your stomach yeah
it was like a we need all this [ __ ] out
of here I justify this once in my
stomach
yeah and I got diarrhea there from that
too
really yeah yeah I know how it got down
there and I had a defecating to a
frisbee out of upside down frisbee was
all I had hey real yeah yeah and so I'm
in this tunnel there were cars whizzing
by here's the crazy thing
yeah extremely hard to poop when cars
are going by 50 60 70 miles an hour and
furious - yeah furious like and also
white people like it was Pittsburgh so
it's furious white people drive by I can
if other people are something certain
ethnicities I can [ __ ] easier when
they're driving by honestly you know
like if a couple of brothers are rolling
by blastings and [ __ ] good music I
can [ __ ] blow ass all day into a
fridge it's no problem part of that you
know everything is everybody's you know
everybody seems like a more laid-back
yeah yeah but an angry white dudes you
know rolling by you know six seven what
they would probably call somebody - huh
oh they weren't calling anybody I mean
the only free finger they had they're
waving it out the window
use it to dial the phone so you [ __ ] on
a frisbee got a [ __ ] in the opened
another you know at the top part but the
bottom part a frisbee is basically a cup
basically the size Oh play it's a plain
plate well ladies is a cup are you a
place is wide wide wide are you pulled
over I pulled it yet I'll pull over the
car I think honest everyone - yes oh
it's dark [ __ ] in a tunnel you play -
yeah okay you should be familiar with
tunnels dude why huh
because because even do that [ __ ] again
right now man why you
no dude you're doing that nom [ __ ] again
ah bro what no I'm one you thought that
I was digging tunnels at the Ho Chi Minh
Trail no I'm the fruit juice the
pomegranate fruit juice that's always no
bro I don't believe in Vietnam I don't
believe it
they never found the boats dude all
right it's just like slavery they never
found the bones
what do you be Turtles overall so anyway
I'm in a tunnel I'm in a tunnel and
there's only two lanes going each way
there's no there's nowhere to get out on
the tunnel like in a tunnel you know
cars are whizzing by yeah and so I had
to get in the backseat and defecated
into this frisbee right and uh
and then wait for the cops to come had
to call the cops
as somebody I I wall somebody not
somebody I had just [ __ ] in a frisbee in
my car and I needed help
yeah there's a lot of things I didn't
learn from that story I'll tell you what
I didn't learn okay something I didn't
learn that a cup a cup and a plate or
the same [ __ ] thing they're not the
same thing depends on yeah spends on who
where you are how strong the gravity is
in an area how fresh the cup how
recently you made it how warm is the
clay a [ __ ] cup is this a plate is a
wide wide cut the sides oh yeah that's
the truth dude Wow go beat a plate apart
with a hammer and then tape it together
yeah and don't do a good job you get
wouldn't bowl be the same as a plate
go beat a couple part I'm sorry with a
hammer that's true you're Latin it out
maybe there's tape it together
what do you have you have a [ __ ]
plate there you got a plate any [ __ ]
one
how does he feel Vaughn I don't know how
you feel good
[Music]